we begin with this the Senate Judiciary
Committee plans to investigate former
acting FBI director Andrew McCabe's
claim that the Deputy Attorney General
actually discuss removing President
Trump from office
under the 25th amendment Andrew McCabe
told 60 minutes Scott Pelley that rod
Rosen Stein brought up the 25th
amendment and was counting votes or
possible votes within the cabinet he
also said that Rosen side offered to
wear a wire into the White House the
Justice Department denied Rosen sign
authorized recording the president and
said he was not in a position to
implement the 25th amendment McCabe says
he gave all the memos of his
conversations with President Trump to
Special Counsel Robert Muller the
Justice Department accuses McCabe of
lying to investigators about sharing
information with reporters the White
House says McCabe opened a quote
baseless investigation into the
president and has no credibility mccabe
denies any wrongdoing and believes his
firing 26 hours before his scheduled
retirement was politically motivated he
is considering suing the Justice
Department for his full benefits McCabe
is also promoting a new memoir the
president tweeted this morning mccabe
and rod Rosenstein looked like they were
planning a very illegal act and got
caught in a portion of the interview you
did not see last night McCabe tells
Scott Pelley about Rosenstein s decision
to hire a special counsel to lead the
Russia investigation Rosenstein took a
little bit of time deciding whether to
appoint a special counsel in this case
what were some of the things he was
thinking about who was he seeking advice
from rod was thinking about a lot of
things during those days there was a lot
going on rod and I had numerous several
interactions over the course of about
five or six days in each one i pressed
and pressed raised the issue press a
little harder rod initially wasn't
convinced that we needed one and then
initially wasn't convinced we needed one
right away I think one of his concerns
that he mentioned to me was that he was
concerned what would happen to him if he
appointed a special counsel that if he
did
it might mean that he would lose his job
and then we would no longer have a
senate-confirmed official at the Justice
Department to oversee all these efforts
he was also concerned about the ongoing
efforts to find and nominate a new
candidate for the FBI Director position
and that was a process that he very much
wanted to stay involved in who was he
seeking advice from I can't say everyone
who rod was seeking advice from because
I don't know that but he did mention to
me that he would he mentioned to me how
highly he thought of Jim Comey and he
mentioned that he would like to speak to
Jim Comey about it after Comey was fired
that's correct Rosenstein had been the
one who wrote the memo that got Comey
fired and now he wants to reach out and
ask him for advice he did he did he
raised the issue with me twice and
ultimately I told him that I wasn't
comfortable connecting him with Jim
Comey that I didn't think Jim should
weigh in on these things
why not because at that point Jim was no
longer a member of the government and it
would have been improper to have him
weighing in on these decisions I felt
McCabe said he did not know whether
Rosenstein and Comey ever eventually
spoke Rosenstein has denied speaking to
Comey about the special counsels
investigation